ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show live from amish country or
wherever the [ __ ] we are we're back in
the studio next week we've had to make
these makeshift studios to try to just
keep the youtube uh
views going uh you know if it was up to
me i'd do an audio only episode but we
know how much that angers you people
uh so we've made a uh a studio here in
the middle of a an airbnb
rented under someone else's name uh in
uh
royersford pennsylvania where i will be
performing in a heated dome
i will be performing stand-up comedy in
a heated
dome in the middle of a field in
royersford pennsylvania
uh tonight tomorrow and
sunday and then uh flying back to texas
which is
healed hopefully from the
snowstorm um
that's what we got here pennsylvania to
me
with all due respect one of the most
worthless
states in the union the food is
atrocious
it's gas station food cheese steaks are
gross
tasty cake is you can taste the
chemicals you can see the
you can you can see the guy the in the
factory
turning on the machine that puts the
layer
you know little quarter inch of chemical
icing on top of it i mean it's
not good everything food wise people
take pride in here
is something that comes out of a gas
station people love wawa
people love wawa they act like wawa
and i'm not immune to the appeal of wawa
i get it
you know what i mean it's it it's a gas
station that's
that has meatballs so i understand why
people love wawa so much because you can
get a sandwich at the gas station
and i understand that and i've i've even
said nice things about wawa
um and i you know big j loves i i get it
you know so if you're on a road trip and
there's nothing else around
and you find you stumble into a wawa
you know good you can get some uh
you know a couple of sandwiches and some
chips it's
you know i remember once me and dan
soder were on the road and there was a
wawa and we walked in and there was a
little chocolate pudding that came with
cookie dough bits to put on top
and um i had them and i was struggling
to put the cookie dough bits in the
pudding and i
dan soder was like kind of helping me
and i was like be careful he goes i know
to you these are diamonds
i was like be very careful i get it i
just don't you know
dan's driving that 45 minutes to get
cheesesteaks to get
steakhums and cheese whiz uh on a
hoagie roll that he's gonna then drive
back i mean it's
am i supposed to be impressed by this am
i supposed to get excited about this
and people get mad at me when i when i
call this out but is this is this
is this the type of place i'm supposed
to feel lucky to be
i don't believe so but i'm sure the
audiences are good the philly audiences
are always great
and uh we're just getting to the end of
the road here you know we've been to
some of the greatest cities in america
we've been to cleveland ohio
columbus ohio providence rhode island
and now royalford pennsylvania
it's been a string of de-industrialized
uh opium addicted hellholes but comedy's
been really really good
columbus is not that per se but it's
kind of bleak and desolate and it's you
know
les wexner is still very much running
the show i mean here's the thing about
guys like les wexner
they at least built a real business
i mean everything else they did the
human trafficking the drug running
i mean there they at least built a
company everyone that
has a hundred million dollars now is
just like bitcoin
it's some gimmick but less wax are
actually built i mean victoria's secret
you can buy a bra
like it actually exists you can go in
and get a pair of fuzzy slippers it's
it's actually
a functional business it's not some
pretend opaque hard to understand
uh you know cryptocurrency that moves up
and down
uh you know because of uh elon musk's
tweets this is an actual
but and sure the cargo planes get used
for
blow and sure they they wash the dark
money
we get it but it it's real
it's not lindsay lohan's nft
do you know that lindsay lohan now has a
non-fungible token
lindsay lohan who is
can i say never relevant lindsay lohan
was relevant when she was
a child right right yeah
and then i mean it's just been a
succession of rehabs
a succession of you know photos of her
collapsed on someone's lawn
and now she's selling a non-fungible
token
for what purpose other than to just bang
her fans over the head
that small group of people that think
it's funny to own a lindsay
lohan nft what is the artwork on it what
does it even look like she's holding up
a diamond
the ethereum diamond that the crypto she
loves and that's it
it's just covering her eye like does she
have real money in crypto
apparently she's all into crypto for the
past year now
her and soulja boy have been going hard
on the crypto and the nft
how much is her nft how much is a
lindsay lohan
token she sold this for uh 17 000 but
she donated
it all to uh save the children
but this is a tax scam she's trying to
this let's be very honest about this
this is a tax scam
and can you explain because you were
explaining it to me
how if you have these nfts and you sell
them
and by the way just because it is a scam
and i'm identifying it as such
doesn't mean or shouldn't restrict me
from getting involved
in doing it so don't don't be one of
those people or go
oh last episode you said it was a scam
in the next episode
you're selling it to us don't be that
don't do that
now we don't have one but i'm saying if
we are if we're to give one or get one
if we're to
pump one up we might ours is not going
to be a scam
theirs is a scam do you understand
lindsay lohan's a
deflating balloon we're on our way up
so if you get involved on the ground
floor what we're doing that's a good
move
but lindsay lohan i mean there's nothing
left here what's the last thing she did
laurel canyon with brett easton ellis
that guy who says tim can you do my
podcast in three years
and i go what he goes we have a it's a
patreon only podcast
we'd like to book you in november me and
my boyfriend are huge fans i'm like
how about because i i asked him to do my
show i'm like how about you do my show
cause it's relevant
okay what's the last thing he's written
by the way what's the last thing he's
done
freddie's tineless it's the last thing
he's done
laurel canyon with lindsay loh what she
was in that i think
yeah she was she was and a porn star and
and by the way brad's done some great
stuff so we're not no
shade to him but when i ask you to be on
the show say yes
don't tell me you have a patreon only
podcast you'd like me to do it
oh he he released his first piece of
non-fiction it was that one called white
it's a collection of essays on
contemporary political culture remember
it was really like
yeah who cares anyway i'm doing bffs
with dave portnoy and josh richards i'm
very excited about that
i like portnoy we make fun of the
barstool people sometimes
but i do like them a lot and i think
they're a force for good
overall in the media landscape so we'll
be doing that podcast on tuesday very
happy about that and brett easton ellis
the offer is still on the table so if
you and your boyfriend
have the time you could come in and chat
with us about what it was like to make
laurel canyon with lindsay lohan
and uh where you think her coin is
headed
now how many lindsay lohan non-fungible
tokens are there
so far there's one there's one token for
17 grand yeah and who bought that
just some guy some guy uh his name is uh
let me let me find his name here because
because what they do is they buy it and
then someone out bids them
because so people don't buy them to own
them they buy them to then sell them for
a higher price
so they get traded all the time like
mark cuban right now is do you know mark
cuban is selling his tweets as
as ntfs i've heard that yeah or nfts
excuse me when i said this was the era
of fake business i had no idea how
correct i was
i had no idea how prescient that rant
would be and how far this would go
we're selling nothing i mean this is
literally nothing now
celebrities did what did kings of leon
do they just sold
an album for 6 million yeah
i mean this is just it seems like
from far away a bad faith attempt
to milk the last amount of remaining
money from your fan base
it seems to me like these are people
that are trying to just bang their fan
base
over the head ring the register
sell them absolute horseshit get
involved in a cultural moment
build this mania convince
people that this is going to be a thing
when they know it's not
it seems like a horrible thing to do
how would we get involved in doing it if
we wanted to
what would be the first step your agent
actually just texted me a company that
we might team up with we didn't fire him
yet
where is and what because to me
it seems why what has kings of leon done
that's worth six
million dollars and whatever i don't
i don't whatever the kings of leon or
whatever fine yeah
uh what's their song isn't it i do you
somebody oh yeah yeah
six million what is it a token which is
the kings of leon
it's the album itself like soulja boy is
selling songs
so you get an album for six million
dollars yeah so you own it but everyone
else no one else
but everyone else could listen to it but
you're the one who owns it you own it so
you can do
well this seems interesting well
well well maybe maybe i was too rash
in my condemnation of this so i own the
kings of leon album
i bought it for six million dollars i
could distribute it how i want
no well it's just available to the
public but you're the one who
tim dillon owns the king of leon so what
is
ownership mean if everyone can listen to
it i don't know
that's what my problem is i don't know
what ownership means what's the equity
in owning something it's like clout
i guess
i don't understand this at all i'm terri
i'm confused
it's absolutely a tax scam this makes
bitcoin seem like the most legitimate
thing i've ever heard
it's absolutely a tax cam because you
would tell me as long as you sell one of
these
you can and and you can prove that you
know what the cost is
yes you've ten of them and this is ray
kump confirmed this is probably true
and you guys are gonna go off in the
comments probably and say we don't know
what the [ __ ] we're talking about
but if you have ten of them you sell one
for ten thousand you can then donate the
other nine
and then you can say you're at a loss of
90 000 because it's appraised at 10 000
each
and then that's a tax write-off right
all goes to charity i don't know if
that's true
i don't know if that's true ray cumps
said it's legit so if i
sold if we could sell a non-fungible
token on this show
and i sold it to the fans and and
i let's say we get 20 000 worth
and i sold one for a grand i could
write off the other 19 000. yeah
yeah and especially if you're donating
everything to charity too now you're
looking at
you know so so i can donate
the 19 000 to charity or it's also a
write-off because it's a loss
because you you could have gained is it
actually so i'm actually donating the
money to charity i'm not giving them the
token
right yeah i'm not handing lindsay
lohan's not handing to save the child
she's not handing the children to the
talking with her with the diamonds she's
giving them the ethereum
that was used to buy the nft which has a
cash value correct
okay and then she gets to write it off
it's not confusing at all folks the
american economy is in great shape and i
don't want you to say it's not
i don't want you to say it's not people
are buying a lot of digital real estate
and video games too so that's another
nft
it can come in like digital is this a
way for cancel people to come back can
kevin spacey launch a coin
can harvey weinstein launch a coin can
harvey weinstein have an nft
i mean let's think about this is there a
way for these people to get
back in the saddle through nft's
non-fungible tokens
is there a token market for people like
o.j simpson who's
really not even canceled but i mean for
people like morgan wallin who said the
n-word in his driveway
can he have a non-fungible token can he
just have an n
can morgan wallace sell a token with an
n on it and that somehow you would
invest in it and you would own the n
word that morgan wallin said
could you own could he just sell the
clip of him yelling the n-word yes and
then you own the end
i own morgan wallen's n-word you could
tell your friends that when you went to
dinner you say i own morgan wallin's
n-word
and you can listen to it but i own it
and they go that's cloud that's pretty
cool
is there a way to is there a way to do
something like that can you just sell
something you've said
yes you could sell just something you've
said
you own the audio version i could sell
the corporate steakhouse rant yes
i could say the tim dillon corporate
steakhouse rant is going for
16 000. and if you want to buy it you
own it now
everyone can listen to it but you own it
you now own my words
so i could sell more than just pictures
i could sell audio
i could sell an album a comedy album i
could sell something like that
jiff of you just dancing cuban sold a
gif of him dancing in the dallas
mavericks jersey
i wonder if like rockefeller and
carnegie and vanderbilt came back i
wonder how disgusted they'd be at the
new crop of people
that have taken their place you know
what i mean like i
i wonder like guys that built bridges
and roads and oil refineries
would sit down and go and now what are
we doing and mark cuban goes i'm selling
this it's
me dancing and uh i mean i'm wondering
if they would be absolutely
horrified by the new crop of
business moguls that we have now elon
musk who's you know selling
nfts on mars he's selling non-fungible
tokens
didn't this thing blow up the other day
oh his spaceship yeah
yeah yeah so that's what you do as a
billionaire you just blow up spaceships
while everyone on earth crawls around
without health insurance
is that kind of the society we've set up
am i wrong we have billionaires just
blowing up spaceships in the sky
while like unemployed school teachers
just crawl around
on the floor looking for [ __ ]
painkillers
i mean is that not the world we've got
if you were an alien and you landed and
somebody explained society to you you go
yeah these guys have billions of dollars
you go well why they go well they blow
up
spaceships they they take spaceships up
in the sky and uh blow them up
i know elon musk is smart guy but he
doesn't retweet me so i don't give a
[ __ ]
but what i'm saying is like these
non-fungible tokens we so we've entered
into a very interesting
so now everything is currency yes is
that kind of where we're going here
everything's now i know there's a
bitcoin expert in the comm in the
youtube comments because they have
they have all the time in the world
these people that are going to yell at
me and tell me i'm an idiot
but i'm admitting i'm an idiot because i
don't know about these things i'm
unaware i'm learning about them on the
fly
you see like you don't know much about
them either idiot in the comments
because
these are new things okay so i'm just
learning so
everything is currency yes and
everything can be traded
and you just got to find a group of
people that are willing to see the value
in something
so as long as someone sees the value in
something no matter how
absurd it is mark cuban dancing what is
why does that have value that mark cuban
is dancing in a gif
i don't know remember after the whole uh
wall street bets thing happened and mark
cuban's like
this this got people like my son to
start taking an interest in stocks
i'm like doesn't you being a billionaire
have
get him to take interest in this what
i mean it's very interesting to me
uh where does this end
how and where does this end is is this a
massive crash
it has to be i mean does this just
bottom out
lindsay lohan hasn't does anyone else
have nfts who else has an nft
soldier boy is big on that okay he's
selling uh songs called crank that
um also the neon cat guy do you remember
neon cat i do not
he was the it's the pop tart cat that
shoots rainbows that went for
477 000. it was a rare gif of the neon
cat
with the pop he's a pop-tart body and
it's a cat's head
it's like a internet
like meme um
i i mean half a million dollars yeah for
the pop tart
with the cat's hat neon cat yeah so that
person gets to own neon cat
just one gif and so um
those are kind of the people on the
front lines of the nft world
could just lane maxwell start at nft
there's so many platforms they'd
probably take her
like why not why shouldn't why can't she
sell an nft of
of of bill clinton [ __ ] an underage
girl
and just say here this is this isn't do
you want to own
bill clinton [ __ ] an underage girl
the cia is going to have a non-fungible
token very soon by the way
the cia will just start slinging nfts
here
here is uh you now own a gif
of the cigarette girl at abu ghraib with
the leash guy
you now own that 250 000
you know why here's a gif of people uh
putting the bombs in the uh building the
thermite in the buildings of 911.
here's a gif of that 380 000
proof it was an inside job just went for
000. i own the [ __ ] 911 nft man
wow there's just not much to say
i i would like to maybe get involved
because everyone else is getting
involved and i feel left
out and just because this is a scam and
it's not based on anything doesn't mean
we shouldn't figure it out and
participate you understand
so next week if we have an nft i don't
want all the people that have listened
to this to start
i don't know getting angry we may have
to delete this episode i guess next week
and just claim that
everyone was experiencing instead
because our nft would be
good if we had an nft we'd link it to
maybe a project that was coming up or
something i don't know
i have a bit i have people that i talk
to about bitcoin that might know
more about this than i do you know
i don't know i just i just think it's an
interesting development in the uh
economic cycle of our country
lindsay lohan is big into cryptocurrency
i mean does that does that not worry
anyone does that not
scare anyone about the future of
cryptocurrencies that lindsay lohan is
out there
selling it and she's i mean i don't know
man
we do what we can do zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving only
140 calories are serving it's keto
friendly gluten free grain free
grain-free soy-free low-carb gmo free
we've got exciting news magic spoon will
be releasing two amazing new flavors
cookies and cream and maple waffle
if you like many other people are
committed to health but want to start
your day with cookies and cream and
maple
waffle comforting indulgent combination
i don't know what it is this is the
ultimate treat yourself combo so make
sure you get some while you can
get it well you can't remember the china
chocolate song
get it while you can don't turn your
back on love
build your own box that's
also you can do that now with your
gender build your own box
you can build a custom brand cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon
magicspoon.com tim dillon who used the
code tim dillon to save five dollars off
magicspoon.com
tim dillon and use the code tim dillon
to save five dollars off
covered spring break is right around the
corner people are going to be sucking
and [ __ ]
manscaped is here to make sure that you
enjoy the party and your pants never
stops
even veronica corningstone wouldn't say
no to this pants party
for everyone preparing for a pants party
this spring break i have an exclusive 20
off discount go to manscape.com tim d
you need manscape you got to clean the
junk up get it ready
for everybody who's going to see it and
enjoy it 20 off free shipping going to
manscape.com
d 20 off with free shipping by going to
manscape.com tim d
say aloha to your new beautiful balls
with manscaped it's the best the crop
uh lawn mower the lawnmower that really
just takes care of its waterproof
cordless body trimmer with a ton of
other liquid formulations to round out
your grooming routine everyone on the
team uses it
it's the best trimmer on the market for
those of you in need of a chest or a
ball shave
third generation tremor features a
cutting edge ceramic blades reduce
grooming accidents thanks to advanced
skin safe
technology and i didn't you didn't know
this manscape also protects against
stds and aids so no more condoms
get off prep you don't need it manscape
is good
if you shave a jug with manscape the
woman will not get pregnant and the man
will
it eight so don't worry about it it's
good
manscape.com tim d twenty percent off
manscape.com
tmd can't wait to get back to
uh texas things are opening up we're
open at 100 capacity in tax
texas no masks the mask mandate has
ended
so you can go out you can do what you're
going to do
damn the variants damn the new strains
i'm just trying to i'm just when can i
get out of this country
when can i fly to somewhere else is my
question
i'm trying to get at it we've been stuck
for a year
in america
[Music]
something just a window just the wind
blew something
so i'm sure that'll be uh now dan will
be off airbnb
and those pieces of [ __ ] went at me
again yes
i cannot believe that do you have that
screenshot saved yeah first of all they
called me fat which is ableist
so i don't know why they're still on
airbnb if they're harassing
people they call me fat which is ableist
um literally the quote was when tim
dillon's fat ass ablest not only trashes
your home but breaks your furniture and
then denies it
lies literal lies ben you were there
yeah
and calls you a desert icon that i did
calls you a desert die [ __ ] pitches to
the world and threatens to burn your
house down
and thousands of his followers threaten
to kill you good job
and says your furniture looks like it
was made by dr and of course no one's
threatening to kill them we're doing
bits
they don't get the humor it's dark humor
uh and says your furniture looks like it
was made by drug addicts
absolutely does thank you joe rogan for
having our back we'll send you all the
free weird no back chairs and let you
come hang and enjoy our view anytime you
want
out i don't have the time they're trying
to ally themselves with my friend joe
rogan what a
what a slimy bunch of rug munchers
they should absolutely
i'm just i'm just saying that uh
there's a lot of cool things happening
we might we might do more with that
wallet idea that was a great that got
two million views chamath retweeted it
a lot of cool stuff came out of that
you know it's tough you're on the road
man and it's very difficult to
stay sane and sobriety which i have 11
years of sobriety
you really understand why people on the
road that do comedy on the road
just stay on the road drinking forever
because there's not much else to do
a lot of these guys go on the road they
[ __ ] some strangers and they stay there
for 20 25 years
they don't build any type of fan base
outside of that they don't put any
content out
and they just die in like uh you know i
don't know the lobby of a la quinta or
something it's a real
bad life comedy's really a horrible life
for most people to do it
which is why you know people just die
they drop dead the greatest comedians
ever greg giraldo and patricia and
all these people died because they they
can't look at
highways anymore they can't i mean it's
just hard to check
into another [ __ ] whatever marriott
courtyard on the side of a [ __ ]
highway
and i'm grateful that the fans are
coming out the shows are so much fun
and we have so much fun at the shows but
the idea
that it you're just living out of a
suitcase
in these situations it's like i can't do
it a lot i'm not gonna do it a lot i
want to be back in my studio i want to
be back
you know we're going to do these mini
tours like four times a year or
something but like we're we're we're not
this
is not going to be on the road 35 40
weeks a year i can't do it
i don't i i can't physically do it i
mean this last year of the pandemic has
allowed me to like
make and create so much cool [ __ ] that
seems such a wide audience
to ju i mean i just can't i can't do it
i can't be out here
i mean it's hard to eat healthy i mean
what you go to these clubs and
the salads are like less healthy than
anything else
because it's they're like doused in
ranch dressing they have like deep fried
bacon you know onto it's like there's
nothing you could do
and there's no gay man gay men aren't
really huge fans of my comedy which is
fine but they also
like for gay guys there's no benefit
straight guys is more of a benefit
because straight women come to comedy
shows
gay guy gay men don't go to comedy clubs
i would never go to a comedy if i wasn't
a comedian i would never go to a comedy
club they're just disgusting
and i mean not the ones i perform at
but the other ones are bad i mean it's
just gay guy wouldn't do it like you
wouldn't go out
and eat that type of food in that type
of environment like if you had ever said
to me before i was a comedian like
hey man you want to go to chuckles or
something i'd be like no i don't
no no i don't i just you know there's
there's
it's an environment that it's built for
what we do which is make people laugh
but it's like it's not
most comedy clubs are not places you
want to spend
lots of time in about an hour and a half
and you go
get me out truly and then there's some
amazing ones that are great and you know
i'm not trying to be ungrateful here and
i'm so happy that they exist
but i'm also just being honest as a
human on earth
saying it like they're they're
disgusting most of them
do you know what i mean do you see what
i'm saying they're gross
they're absolutely filthy and disgusting
and some of the people that work there
are some of the most depressing people
you'll ever meet
i mean they come in and every ever
their lives are just a succession of
horrors you're in the green room and
these people come in and start telling
me
they're divorced and the dog's sick and
every you know and
everybody's dead and dying and remember
this guy
and then i'm uh i'm somewhere in the the
south and the guy's coming in and he's
telling me how many country music stars
coming to the place
and he's like he's like you know dirk's
bentley i'm like no i don't can you
leave
i'm trying to get my head together here
so i can go out and entertain people but
i get it keep and by the way support
these places please
i'm not saying not to support them be
because they are real businesses they're
not
you know it's not a non-fungible token
it's an actual place you're seeing
actual live stand up
one of the last bastions of free speech
but let's also
be a little honest
about what a lot of these places are a
lot of them are in malls
and a lot of them are just not
really great
some of them are but some of them are
not and
i hope they survive and i want them to
survive but maybe they'll evolve
maybe they'll evolve and the food will
get better and they'll look a little
cooler i don't know what the next
iteration of these things are
but like you know
i mean the real bad ones are like like
bonkers in like a hotel
literally like a hotel conference room
where you get up and like they've
the people that like would have gone to
the live gator park that day
have been persuaded to go see you do
comedy in the uh in the uh conference
room of a uh
uh like uh howard johnson's hotel and
they
they're called bonkers can you imagine
and earn florida
and support them but can you imagine
[Laughter]
one room's at like a bass pro shops or
something right why not
why not and then you go in
and you earn like i mean i'm earning
good money because people are buying
tickets
but you go into like bonkers and you're
on a makeshift stage
in a in a conference room in like
florida
and you're saying yourself it's just
feels old a lot of the way these
places are configured there's they have
not evolved since the 80s
like the comedy club has not made a
massive transition
and it shouldn't be that here's the
thing it shouldn't evolve that much like
it should
i like the older ones where it's darker
smaller
low ceilings but like some of the newer
ones are the ones that were built in the
80s and 90s
they look like like a high-end bowling
alley like imagine that it's like a
high-end bowling alley
you know and it just so i think the next
run after we do some of these clubs
which i love
we might get into music venues we might
try to find cool weird
places i did a theater in toronto once
it was great it was like cold
people like vaping in the theater
everyone had their jacket on it felt
like a homeless shelter but like
it was a lot of fun um but the comedy
club has not evolved much
in the in the time that and i get it the
last year has been very hard for these
clubs
and you should go out to support them
but just notice that i'm a little right
when you do look around and go yeah this
is it's
dated but everything's dated i guess you
go around the country most things are
dated there
there are still malls you know people
still go out to the mall
and eat a pretzel and walk around and
try on clothes in a fitting room
and you go no you don't do that you buy
the clothes on the internet
you don't go to the mall anymore you
don't have to go to the mall
i understand that it's nice i guess
to walk around a mall but you don't have
to do it
you're walking around a mall you almost
feel like you're walking around alcatraz
you're walking around a place that
shouldn't exist anymore and does
and it's weird and then the food court's
there
and uh they've always got like a chinese
restaurant
a chinese restaurant with like a weird
name it's always kind of vaguely racist
you know it's like mr
wangs or something and it's just people
that you'll just see people they're just
eating lo mein
with like a dickies bag and they just
want to go
get put a pants on at dickies and now
they're going to eat [ __ ]
lo mein 3 000 calories ms and msg
and go home and the pants don't fit you
know
it's it we haven't figured out a lot of
[ __ ] on this planet we're not evolving
that quickly you'd think we'd be
evolving at a little quicker pace we're
really not
because the only other option is the
internet which also sucks because you
get it doesn't fit
you're on the internet that's alienating
and sad you're like jacking it and then
you're like all right i gotta buy
clothes and then
i'm fighting with my aunt on facebook
and then what i want an nft
and it's not good you've set up this
digital world for yourself that sucks
but the real world also sucks like now
that things are opening you start to
realize
man the real world kind of sucks a
little bit too
not all of it there's some great things
out there but a lot of the things
like there's no evolution like we
haven't built a cooler newer version of
them all
there's no cooler newer version of these
things
you know what i mean like it just feels
the only the only thing we've done is
made them for rich people
so we've just built malls for wealthy
people like we've made malls and go whoa
everything's gucci and here's
sugar fish sushi and and that's all
we've done but there's
there's not a lot of new things
happening
out there but we you know and you'll
notice this as you open up
opening up is going to be very
interesting someone's going to be out
there like this is
[ __ ] great and they're going to look
around and go the country's kind of
shocked
they're gonna be like finally i'm back
uh you start looking around you start
noticing
how decrepid most things are you might
walk right back in your house
after that by the way you might tiptoe
right the [ __ ] back in your front door
sit down and say [ __ ] it cause when you
go back out you realize
that covid was the nail in the coffin
for just said like a lot of these
businesses
and a lot of these you know the public
parks are
bad like the public park is just
homeless in the park
and there's there's like hiking trails i
guess
in parts of the country but the country
looks bad it looks shot
the country is a cancer patient the
country's on dialysis
the country's got a late stage venal
disease
and and and we are like we're all going
to go back out in it and then start to
realize that like oh
things things need help we need to like
things need a little lipstick and rouge
out there it's not
you know we were in a restaurant the
other day uh of friday's type of
restaurant that we had to be in
and you're looking around and i know
these places have been through hell so
don't
yell at me and go you know like when i
uploaded that photo of cleveland of the
the steel mill and i'm like
cleveland's a lovely city and they go
that's american steel
what do you want the tachoms to do to
steal i'm like no it just looks gross
i'm sorry it looks bad i know it serves
a
function it's just it's all smog and
smoke and it looks like [ __ ]
i understand could we have a city with
steel plants and not have people walking
around dressed in reynolds rap
is that possible that we don't have to
have boarded up houses and people
walking around in cellophane
that's all i'm sorry i i wasn't making
an anti-steel post
on my instagram but how how perceptive
of you that's
american steel dummy good
i'm just saying when you get back out
there it's not gonna be
i don't know what you're expecting it's
like not seeing someone for a while
you don't see someone for a while and
then they walk in and you go
god god
how's it been you know how bad you look
if somebody comes up to you and they're
like how's it been
have you been you okay you okay
like that's what america's gonna look
like when we all go back and go you okay
okay are you okay just waitresses
shaking trying to put entrees down on
the table
nobody's had any money everybody's spent
all their money on soldier boys nft
cities are just descending into chaos
you have just people shooting each other
all the time
crime is on the rise everywhere
except online except it is on the rise
online you know
it's like school shootings came back as
soon as
indoor classes started mark norman had a
tweet it was like we're back
school shootings are back i mean i want
everything to open up and i want to go
back out there but also realize what's
coming with that it's not all going to
be sunshine and song
there's going to be some i mean kids
have not shot each other in
a year like they're ready to go kids are
ready to shoot each other their teachers
administrators they're ready to go on
like day one that kid came in and just
started firing wildly on day one
i mean i think the teachers should start
shooting the kids when they go back
i hope teachers start shooting kids when
schools open up again
i hope teachers just turn around and
start shooting them in their little
[ __ ] heads
that's what i hope happens that's what's
gonna happen when things open up
when things open up you can go out to
eat people are gonna forget your
balsamic vinaigrette again and you're
going to sit there with your hands
clenched
and you're going to want to go up and
hit them they're going to bring the
appetizers and the entrees at the same
[ __ ] time
like they don't know that's a problem
again that's coming back
yes you'll be able to leave your house
yes but things are coming back with it
the long line at the car wash will be
back
because people aren't afraid crowded
public transportation is coming back
it's all back you could sit in a movie
theater next to some vector of disease
a diner where you can watch a divorced
dad try to bond with his son who hates
him
that's all coming back you're gonna have
to see your
family again thanksgiving might [ __ ]
happen this year
you're gonna have to sit down next to
aunt q anon and
uncle drunk touches you and you're gonna
have to sit there
and choke down mashed potatoes next to
those two
all because of this dumb vaccine which
we could have just avoided
thanksgiving's gonna be back your office
is back you haven't seen doreen in a
while
she's back hi we're back
who wants coffee the office office
life's coming back
sit there and talk to chuck he just
started watching the americans
he thinks he's living next to a
communist spy chuck's going to fill you
in on that in the break room
that's coming back get excited your kids
are going to go to start
going to school again it's going to be
much easier for them to get heroin and
[ __ ] in the mouth that's happening
your daughter's gonna have a venereal
disease in about six months because we
vaccinated everybody and we're ready to
go so that's back
if she doesn't get shot in the face by
one of these anti-social kids who spent
the last 12 months reading about bitcoin
so that's back you happy you happy you
got your second shot
and you're back now traffic will be back
it's already kind of back
you could sit in traffic you got that
long commute to work
pass by billboards of televangelist and
healthcare companies that denied you
you could pull in your little [ __ ]
thing at your data entry job
go in there sit down next to somebody
named michelle
and you guys sit there and you walk in
and there's a crusty donut left from
yesterday but you just put that down
your throat
and you get to have a nice [ __ ]
caramel latte that's 2 800 calories
and it buzzes you up for only 45 minutes
and then you got to start taking the
pills
cause nothing else works that's coming
back
open it up open it all
up it's coming
and don't you worry about it i'm just
saying
hey i know we need to open up but let's
do it with open eyes
let's open up with open eyes here
maybe we don't have to go back to
everything we did
maybe we can be smarter and safer okay
about some of the things that we used to
do
you know that's all that's all i'm
saying i'm not saying don't be excited
about i'm excited about it
i'm excited about everything
opening up again and i want to see
everyone i've missed for the last
year it i've been very all these young
kids are killing themselves
because they i have no friends
i'm going to kill myself when i'm forced
to see my friends again
do you understand the difference i've
been on the planet long enough to know
you don't kill yourself when you have no
friends
it's a mark of virtue to not have any
friends most people don't realize that
it's actually biblical christ didn't
have any friends
exactly but i'm excited for things to
come back
i know that people don't people probably
say i feel like he's not but i am it's
going to be fun things are coming back
we're going to do a bunch of crazy cool
[ __ ] uh when we're allowed to do it at
capacity really cool weird comedy
experiences
uh that we're trying to work with
different people and companies and
investors to do and
and [ __ ] like that and i'm pumped about
it
i just i just know that it's going to be
funny because and it's just human nature
everyone is begging for everything to
open because we need it to open by the
way there's no other option we can't
just stay in our homes
but it's just going to be funny the
first time you start complaining again
about
the open world because that'll have like
the first time you're like oh
[ __ ] first time you walk into a store
she's packed
you're like [ __ ] this it's true it's
coming the first
complaint you have about remember how
nice l.a was with no traffic when
everyone was scared to death they were
scared in their homes
they were just scared terrified of
leaving their homes
the way it should be and then
now the traffic's back out people are
having quincy and errors under b get off
the beach
they're doing quinceaneras on the beach
in malibu
they're they're smashing pinatas on in
malibu on the beach
clean it up and echo and i'm not
it's keen seeing the era because it
that's what i saw
i don't care if it was i don't want a
white [ __ ] there with a pinata either
don't come at me i'm just saying there's
a lot of
fun stuff that's going to be happening
very soon
that will also anger you i've gotten a
little used to
um not seeing as many people
and i'm gonna obviously get used to
seeing more of them
which will be lovely and my fam i guess
i'll have to see my
i guess at some point i will have to see
my family
my mother's in her nursing home they've
just locked her up no one can see her
i just wavered her through the window
and tell her what nft to buy
now i'm gonna have to go in there and
actually talk to her
which is fine but d you got to realize
what's about to happen here folks are
you prepared you got to just get ready
for it
bob and weave bob and you got to get
ready for it
many of you think you want it until it's
here
it's like anything you think you want it
and then it's here and then you're like
wait what but this digital hell can't
last
that's true we need to go out and see
people we need humanity we need real
friends
we need to look at them we need to
realize why we didn't talk to them that
much over the last year because they're
non-essential to us
that's the other thing if you didn't
talk to someone over the last year
it's really like i mean i know you'll go
out you'll patch those friendships to an
extent but like
there's going to be a lot of people that
reconnect with you after this whole
thing where you could be sitting there
going looking at them going i don't need
you
this year showed you what you needed
what you need you don't
need a lot of things and people you
don't this year simplified our lives in
a weird way
it complicated them but it also
simplified them you know what i mean
like i realize that all i need is
ben and then on the other side of this
camera 500 000 domestic terrorists
i don't need a lot i just need half a
million people many of whom are on a
watch list
and him i'm not i don't need a ton of
other
things going on in my life you know
you know i need a couple of good looking
gentlemen with
six packs or a little younger that want
gucci shoes
that's what i need i don't need an
endless supply of social interactions i
find them to be
a little meaningless but i'm getting
older to 36
you're getting older you know i get it
if this happened i was 22 i'd be like
man of [ __ ] i can't believe it
dude what now i'm like i'm dr
i'm like dreading i pray every day i
turn on the tv i pray for the new strain
i pray that people's faces start melting
off with this
i go come on can i roll the dice i'm
like give me brazil
give me brazil because i'm just trying
to avoid thanksgiving so i'm like
roll the dice come on give me something
from pakistan give it to me good
i don't know it won't be over that soon
but it'll be over soon enough
i i do hope it ends we need new things
we need new things to be angry at and
mad at and we need new
uh challenges in life we need to go out
there and people need to [ __ ] again and
meet each other and have physical
relationships you know i mean i get it
you know but
it's a very interesting thing to be just
let out of the cage
just let out of the cage like
here's the reality when you let the kids
out of the ice cage many of them were
like hey man
it sucked in there but this is also bad
wherever they put them i don't know you
know what i mean
should i broadcast for one of the biden
administration ice cages
for a week because biden hasn't shut
them down either
just go live just go live should i just
do like a 48-hour live event
from a detention from an immigration
detention facility
i mean can we sell
immigrant children as nfts
to release them that that's a question
can we sell children detained
at the immigration center as nfts can
mark cuban do that
can mark cuban take a picture of a child
in a cage dancing
sell it raise the money to get that
little guy out
and we'd have to explain to him jose
you're an nft
now you're a non-fungible token
okay you're a non-fungible token you're
out of here
we turn to the next one and go you're
not a non-fungible token yet
back in i'm laughing i of course are for
abolishing the cages so don't get angry
at me i don't want any children in cages
and i never did so don't
oh tom i'm making fun of a horrible
situation you know
i also didn't want the my life massacre
you know i'm not involved in the
decision making
it's happening here by the way raycon
wireless these are the best headphones
on the market folks enough with apple
stop giving that cult more power raycon
is great they're built to perform
anywhere and anytime with water and
sweat resistant construction
and bluetooth that pairs quickly and
seamlessly enough battery life for six
hours of play time you can unplug for a
while the best part
raycon makes great sound accessible to
everyone with wireless earbuds
starting at half the price of other
premium audio brands it's really amazing
it's great even if you haven't lost your
earpods yeah buy some raycon's anyway
just in case you do
you start using the raycons you're going
to switch they're great raycon's
offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
and that's what you got to do
go get it raycon.com tim that's it
you'll save 15
off your entire order that's raycon.com
tim it's the best headphones
you're gonna love them i love them
celebrities use them
um that's what's important is what
celebrities do uh
you could do six hours of playtime you
don't have to charge recharge it's great
raycon.com tim blue chew baby
quarantine's being lifted and
everybody's gonna be out there sucking
and [ __ ] you gotta take bluetooth
make sure your dick is hard
bluetooth.com is great
it has the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but initial form and a
fraction of the cost bluetooth tablets
help men achieve harder stronger
erections to combat
all forms of ed it's an online
prescription service no visit to the
doctor's office awkward conversation no
waiting in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discrete package the process is simple
sign
up at bluetooth.com consult one of the
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online
blue chews licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength for your
prescription don't like swallowing pills
no problem here blue chews sliding fall
and talented fall
tablets are chewable they're chewable
they're made in the usa and they prepare
and ship direct
so it's cheaper than a pharmacy so if
you could benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to perform
visit bluetrue.com for more details use
your promo code td to receive your first
month free bluetooth.com promo code td
you get your first month free so don't
comment me i just i want to know what
the limits to the nfts are that's my
point
i'm wondering what what what when does
it
end what can we you know
do porn stars start selling an nft of
them just
oh for sure yeah yeah
yeah and once things once we get into
the virtual world you know people are
buying digital real estate in these
virtual worlds they could buy a private
prison
in the digital world and then free the
people out of it
what people though the digital people in
the in the game because in the video
games people are buying houses because
they're like well this house
but that's fine but i want the private
prisons on earth to be
secure is there a way to do that let's
free the people in the game
it's a good idea but let's let's close
the private prison in the game it's a
phenomenal idea
but keep it on earth i think it's a gr
it's a great idea
we're escaping fully into a digital
world now fully as we're opening back
up which is hilarious you're gonna open
back up and go what the [ __ ] am i doing
out here at fuddruckers doesn't make any
sense
i just want to go back and live in the
digital world where i mean
something i can close private prisons in
the digital world
i can't do anything out here i could go
listen to tim dillon yell in a bowling
alley
but there's nothing for me to do i can
drive to my
shitty strip mall office sit there and
try to rob people of their healthcare or
whatever industries are left in this
country
or i could [ __ ] buy some nfts and buy
some digital real estate what the [ __ ]
is digital real estate
it's this game it's decentraland like
people are just buying plots of land in
the game
right good i guess why not
can't do it here do it in the game
do it in the game get the operation in
the game make political change in the
game
we just selected a humanitarian in the
i i mean it's truly seems to be our only
option not to sound dystopian about it
but it seems to be our only option i i
don't see
is there a real world fix coming this
seems to be a good option
just play the game and do the things in
the game that you can no longer do on
earth
sounds good sounds good to me
we're just opening the doors here but
it's like you're allowed back out now
you're like but everything's digital
everything i care about all the money is
digital nobody accepts my money now
i i own a lindsay lohan nft can i get a
sandwich with that
i have soldier boy nfts they go what i
don't have any physical money
they didn't send me the unemployment
checks i only have an eighth of a
bitcoin
and a soldier boy nft what can that get
me
i have to go to the dentist and pay with
[ __ ] mark cuban gifs
like it's just very interesting you have
two things colliding you have
we're falling further into the digital
world at the same time we're going back
out into the world
and these this collision of these things
is going to be very interesting to watch
over the next uh
few months and and coming years
gonna be very interesting because even
though we're opening up as we should and
need to
there seems to be just a complete
surrender in many meaningful ways
to the digital landscape and living
there forever
yeah wow
heavy concepts folks heavy concepts
we'll all see how it works i don't know
how it'll work
we'll try to be funny if if we're
allowed to be you know
seems to be twitter you said they're
just getting rid of everyone
yeah just a it's a real purge you know
mostly of the alt-right accounts and
fringe ride accounts
but pretty much i think everyone will be
game over the next year as they become
more of like a patreon type platform is
that what we see twitter evolving into
yeah so people are gonna start paying to
subscribe you saw subscribe
to tweets like vip tweets you pay five
dollars a month and you can see like tim
dillon's tweets but just for his
followers that pay
that's the new subscription service with
twitter so is this a way of not seeing
other people's tweets
can you curate your own timeline is that
is that no you you can just see special
tweets that you are only letting people
who pay
to see but doesn't that sound like the
way to get the most racism
right i guess yeah doesn't that sound
like the way to get them
like hey wink wink this is a special
tweet just for you
these goddamn dot heads at the gas
station like i mean what
what do you think that's going to be
used for that's going to be used for
you know fitness advice you're saying
they're purging disney plus now too
they're trying to they have this new
algorithm that's identifying
things that could be racist in disney
movies yeah let me find this direct
quote right here
um multiple hollywood companies have
been using an artificial intelligence
program designed by researchers from
usc's
vitterby school of engineering to
analyze films and shows for issues like
gender representation and violence
now one studio also is weighing using
a.i to scan scripts in its archive for
content like racial slurs
so you have films like gone with the
wind now so if someone's gonna watch
gone with the wind
on one of these platforms there's now a
four-minute intro
into the movie where they explain that
racism is bad
before you watch it i mean christ
almighty
listen up before you watch the feature
presentation we hear it
would like you to know disney plus would
like you to know that
slavery is not good it is bad
and it was wrong and the civil war was
fought
not to end slavery but to preserve the
union
do you see so these people that you're
watching
are part of the problem and what'd you
say there's a disclaimer before aladdin
yeah before aladdin so
films will that it says this film
includes harmful stereotypes or harmful
deposits what
is that is that a harmful stereotype
about arabs that they are on magic
carpets
that's the best stereotype about them
there is think about that
i mean if you heard a group of people
could fly on a carpet you guys cool as
[ __ ]
you think after 9 11 that's the
stereotype we should be fighting
is it that genies come out of lamps
that's cool that's really cool
i'm sure if you gave an arab person a
choice ago what should we believe about
you
that you can summon genies and fly on a
carpet or
that you're strapped with a bomb maybe
they'd go neither but if you said well
if we had to believe one thing they'd go
i would go with the genies
seems like i would get stopped at the
airport less
yeah the the actual thing it'll pop up
it'll say this program includes negative
depictions and or mistreatment of people
or cultures
these stereotypes were wrong then and
are wrong now and then the movie starts
okay before like the jungle book dumbo
aladdin why is the j what happened in
the jungle book
i i don't know he's indian so i guess
it's cause he's like naked
maybe it's showing that he's like poor
or something is any indian in it he
lives in the jungle
are they gonna do this with white things
like the chronicles and narnia are they
gonna go
uh the white witch being like the
ultimate white woman [ __ ]
who like lures edmond in in into working
for her by
offering him turkish delight is a wrong
stereotype no it's
like dude we thought mowgli was cool as
a kid because he was like hanging out
with bears in the jungle
what every other thing back then was
like a fat white kid who's like oh
chocolate it was like you know like and
then like mowgli was like
thin and lived in the jungle he was like
in shape you were like oh good for him
as a kid you were like mowgli's figured
it out his best friend's a bear
they hang out together every day and the
other option was like just some like
pale-faced pasty british kid
like just [ __ ] like eating a candy
bar or something i mean what are we
talking about here
this is nonsense
and what in dr seuss now they get rid of
because the grinch is a jew or something
who cares doesn't matter
didn't they that's what they found out
right that the grinch was a jew yeah
sure
so what i'm serious i think that's why i
think that's why they
got rid of that because they found out
the grinch's last name was cohen the
grinch's name was barry cohen
and they are mad at that they're mad at
that
she didn't like i get it christmas does
get annoying
there's so much red and green i'm aware
i don't know folks anyway upcoming dates
most of them are sold out but you can
grab tickets on the website
timdilliancomedy.com
i'm always happy to be on the road i
love comedy clubs and go no i'm kidding
i do
and it is funny to be uh out again and
we'll be back out i just got to go home
and sleep in my own bed
i'm very excited that the country's
opening up as i have detailed and i'm
also very excited about the non-fungible
tokens
which are absolutely 100 legitimate ways
to support your favorite artist and or
artists
so we'll be looking into doing them too
because you deserve it
and uh i just think it's great i think
it's all great
and i'm excited about it and i'm excited
about what's to come
so you should be too and uh
it's going to be a lot of fun out there
and and even when problems arise i'm
sure we will do what we've always done
as a country
work together and come up with a
coordinated response and just get
get better because that's what we do we
just get better
and i feel very good about the state of
the economy i feel very good the
billionaires are selling gifs of
themselves dancing
i feel great about it i feel great about
people blowing up spaceships
while vast numbers of people are in
poverty i feel
absolutely great about this and i don't
know why you don't
i don't know why you are in this prison
of negativity
buy real estate in the game online and
close the private prison free the people
into prison
online i don't understand the negativity
constantly emanating from you people
everything is good everything is good
everything is good and everything is
money
so what's the [ __ ] problem everything
out there is money so don't worry that
you don't have any of the money that
you're used to and that you recognize
everything is coming together
lindsay lohan has sold a non-fungible
token
for 17 000 to some
stalker or somebody who will probably
kidnap her you should be able to kidnap
her by the way
uh if you buy her non-fungible token you
should be able to kidnap her
that should be in the rules that should
be allowed um
so just don't despair things are
good and i'm very happy and we're very
happy to be back
out on the road uh and we'll be
we'll be back soon back in the studio
because i can't where the [ __ ]
am i i mean where are we i can't i don't
know man i mean this is rough man
what who's this what life is this who's
this for
get me an nft get me out of here oh
before we leave to tim
ev everybody's dming me asking you ah
they want me to ask you what you think
about cuomo
what's going on with him right now i
mean these people are you over are you
over it
i just i don't know about the listen
yeah was he creeped to women maybe but
he's also been an
incredibly corrupt and inept leader he's
been a very very bad governor
for years and no one seems to have cared
and now like
he like pinched someone's ass at a
christmas party and everyone's like
oh he's got to go it's like what about
the nursing home genocide
how about the doc how he set up in
nursing homes does anyone care about
that
does anyone have any care about uh
andrew cuomo's little auschwitz he set
up there on long island
okay i'm no fan of the cuomo
family and they know that or maybe they
don't but whatever
i'm just not a fan of them but i think
you should do an nft
i think you should do a non-fungible
token of him just grabbing that chick's
tit
because i think that would make it all
okay
i'll tell you that you know
we should sell non-fungible tokens to
people who die to covet
why not nft covet deaths
just taking pictures of people at the
end smile
you're an nft you're a non-fungible
token
smile your money now
why not turn the 500 000 people who died
of covet into money
are we stupid why not
turn kova deaths into currency
i can't think of any reason not to and
i'm appalled that it hasn't been thought
up
go take a photo of everybody on the at
the end
ventilated and they should now be money
they should be money too if lindsay
lohan
can be money then people that have died
of coven should be mon
i should be able to go and trade covet
deaths
and i think that's where we're heading
in this country and i'm excited about it
and you should be too i'm excited about
the idea
that one day sometime soon
you can own covet deaths
as currency why not
why not absolute currency
you know why not
we're going to do a a guest episode
today and the
guest didn't show up
yeah legit legit we're gonna have a
guess who didn't show up
who was it
i'm trying to get the name because it's
like a it's a comedian
crystalia